بمكالمه هاتفيه مفاجاه بمنتصف الليل منعت
واشنطن اندلاع حرب نوويه بين الهند
وباكستان في عام 2019 وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق بوب بيو قال في كتاب
مذكراته ان الهند وباكستان اقتربتا من حرب
النوويه في فبراير عام 2019 وان تدخل
الولايات المتحده منع التصعيد هذه الحادثه
كانت عندما شنت الهند غرام جويه داخل
الاراضي الباكستانيه بعد ان القت باللون
على جماعه مسلحه هناك بتنفيذ تفجير
انتحاري اسفر عن مقتل 41 جنديا هنديا في
كشمير بدورها اسقطت باكستان طائره هنديه
واثرت الطياره رحلها وقال بومبيو الذي كان
همم موجود لحضور قمه بين الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب و زعيم كوريا الشماليه كيم
جون انه استيقظ على مكالمه عاجله من مسؤول
هندي وكتب
انه المسؤول الهندي وكتب ايضا انه المسؤول
الهنديه يعتقد بان الباكستانيين بداوا في
اعداد اسلحتهم النوويه لتنفيذ ضربه وقبلغ
ان الهند تفكر في تصعيدها والرد سريعا قبل
ان تتخذ باكستان الخطوه واشار بومبيو في
كتاب مذكره بانه طلب من المسؤول الهندي
الا يفعل شيئا ويمنحهم مقتا لبحث الامور
كاشفا ان الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين اقنعه
الهند وباكستان حينها بان اي منهم ما لم
يستعد لاستخدام الاسلحه النوويه واعتبر
انه لم يكن بوسع اي دوله اخرى ان تفعل ما
فعلته للولايات المتحده المتمثله طبعا
باداره الرئيس
في تلك الليله لتجنب نتيجه مروعه على
العالم كله وليس على الهند وباكستان فقط
وفقا طبعا لكم مذكراتها
[موسيقى]